[Music]
let's get an update on the coveted
relief bill negotiations senate majority
leader mitch mcconnell joins us this
evening good evening sir
hey mike are you confident there will be
a deal on a coveted 19 relief bill by
the end of this week sir
lost i sure hope so uh the discussions
uh
continue i think both sides want to get
to an outcome
uh that's the good news the bad news is
we are a long way apart
and we'll see but
look i think the american people need an
outcome it can only be done on a
bipartisan basis
we need to work our way through our
differences and
come up with a solution that helps once
again
focus what i think we need to apply the
focus to
kids in school health care
jobs and liability protection so that
doctors hospitals
nurses universities k-12
our whole society is not afflicted with
a epidemic of lawsuits on the heels
of the pandemic that we're all wrestling
with
delaware senator chris coons in an
interview with brett was critical of you
for not being engaged in this
past weekend's negotiations and he
predicts negotiations will lead to
another 2.3 trillion dollar aid package
similar to the cares act take a listen
it shouldn't have come to this where
you've got literally 30
million americans who are relying on the
additional
unemployment insurance assistance from
the federal government to get them
through this very difficult time
we should have been able to come to a
resolution at this point
how do you respond well i am involved
i've been involved
continuously and the secretary of the
treasury
and the president chief of staff are
briefing my colleagues on a daily basis
we're totally involved in this
the question is can we work together to
get an outcome
uh there are two things that are in
trouble
and need to be dealt with unemployment
and the ppp the popular small business
loan program both expiring right we need
to do a lot more than that
but that certainly creates a sense of
urgency and i haven't sensed the sense
of urgency on the other side that i'd
like to see
mike to actually get an outcome here
house speaker nancy pelosi is taking
aim at your republican conference being
divided
they don't have the votes they have the
votes for practically nothing they
haven't passed anything
they refused to spend more money by and
large in the republican
caucus and again that's a formula for
further disaster do your members
recognize that by being kind of all over
the place on covet relief they're giving
much of the leverage to leader schumer
and
speaker pelosi well in the end
it's going to have to be done on a
bipartisan basis it is correct as i've
said repeatedly i've got 15 or 20 of my
members who believe that we've
already added quite enough to the
national debt we have a debt now the
size of our economy for the first time
since world war
ii so yeah there are differences of
opinion but that wouldn't get an outcome
the only thing gets an outcome
is the speaker and the president united
states
reaching an agreement and once they do
that
i believe that the majority of my
members will support it
but not every single one of them and
i've been clear about that from the
beginning
there's been some discussion about
bringing rapid testing to capitol hill
after
texas congressman louis gomer tested
positive last week house gop leader
kevin mccarthy
called for rapid testing for lawmakers
staff and reporters
speaker pelosi deferring to the capital
physician where are you on this testing
issue sir
well believe it or not i agree with the
speaker i think we have to continue to
consult with the capital position
about what should be best practice for
us i must say on the senate side we've
been wearing a
mask and practicing social distancing
and have
been in session almost continuously
since may the first
and we're doing fine so i think we are
demonstrating ourselves that you can
learn to live with the coronavirus until
we get the vaccine we're going to have
to learn to live with it
that means wearing mass doing social
distancing and working smartly and
safely
until we finally get a vaccine after
which we can put this awful experience
in the rearview mirror
finally sir sports a huge part of our
culture you've got the derby coming up
in a month
you've got proud programs at the
university of kentucky in louisville
your thoughts on sports here in the
covered era well i'm still hoping like a
lot of other sports fans that we can
and we can figure a way to safely play
during this pandemic i think it's
important for the american public to get
back to normal as much as possible
and with many of these athletic events
apparently it's going to be with
limited or no audience but we'll all be
watching on tv and i hope we can
have as much normal return to sports
safely as possible all across america is
it better to have a derby with no fans
and at least run the race than
than having no derby at all yeah it's
better to have a derby even if there
aren't any fans in the stand
we were sorry to have to cancel it back
in may but i think it's going to go off
on labor day weekend we look forward to
that senate majority leader mitch
mcconnell
thanks so much for your time sir thank
you